البدايه من الجاردين البريطانيه التي تقول
ان سكان غزه يواجهون ازمه جوع كارثيه
وتضيف ان خطر المجاعه يتزايد كل يوم بسبب
اشتداد القتال حيث اصبح الغذاء نادرا
وباهظ الثمن وبات من الصعب العثور على
الوقود اللازم للطهي والوضع في شمال غزه
هو الاسوا حيث يقضي 90% من السكان يوما
كاملا وليله كامله دون تناول
الطعام قال الكاتب انشل فيفر في مقاله
بالتايم ان معركه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو المقبله هي انقاذ حياته السياسيه
حيث تواجه حكومه الحرب التي يراسها حاله
من الاضطراب ويضيف الكاتب ان حماس لم تهزم
كقوه عسكريه ولا تزال تمثل تهديدا كبيرا
فالالاف من مقاتليها يختبئون في الانفاق
ويختلطون مع السكان المدنيين نشرت تدعو
احرونوت تحليلا قالت فيه ان حماس تتعلم
الدروس في حربها وتتحرى نقاط الضعف في
الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد كل معركه استعدادا
لجوله اخرى من القتال في اليوم التالي كما
تظهر حماس صبرا خلال القتال ربما كان
مخططا له مسبقا وبراعه في زياده استخدام
القناصين طالبتها ارتس في افتتاحيتها
بايقاف القتل الجماعي في غزه معتبره ان
الهجوم واسع النطاق المتواصل من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يسفر عن اي نتائج فيما
يتعلق بالرهاب وشددت على ان اعاده الرهائن
من الاهداف الاساسيه للحرب ولا تملك حكومه
نتنياهو اي تفويض بالتخلي
عنهم نشرت صحيفه تايمز اوف ازريل مقالا
بقلم افرايم عنبار رئيس معهد القدس
للاستراتيجيه والامن قال فيه ان الحرب على
حماس لم تنتهي بعد لكن بعض الدروس تبدو
واضحه للغايه اهمها ان اسرائيل تحتاج الى
جيش اكبر ويتعين عليها ايضا ان تقلل
اعتمادها على الولايات المتحده في مجال
الاسلحه فد وافع واشنطن في دعم اسرائيل
مشبوهه بنظر الكاتب لهوس بحل الدولتين
قالت النيويورك تايمز ان جماعه الحوثي في
اليمن تمثل تحديا خاصا للولايات المتحده
فقد شنت اكثر من 100 هجوم على السفن
التجاريه في البحر الاحمر خلال الشهر
الماضي فقط ويقول محللون عسكريون انه من
المحتمل ان تتخلى اداره بايدن عن صمتها
اذا استمرت الهجمات وفي الوقت نفسه يؤرق
هاجس توسع الصراع وتصعيده تفكير المسؤولين
الامريكيين اشارت الوول ستريت جورنال الى
ان الهجوم في المحيط الهندي على ناقله نفط
مؤشر على تزايد المخاطر على الشحن بعد
هجمات الحوثيين في البحر الاحمر ويقول
خبراء ان الهجوم في المحيط الهندي يثير
تساؤلات بشان ما اذا كان التحالف بقياده
الولايات المتحده قادرا فعليا على الدفاع
عن منطقه اكبر سبع مرات من
اوروبا